This is Maya Fischler. I'm in the home of Jean Starker-Raw and today is November
13th 2007. Today, Jean and I are going to be talking about some of the community
activities that she's been involved with and I'd like to ask her some questions
as well on a more philosophical side of things asking her to reflect a little
bit about her life and some of the things that she's accomplished. Okay. So when
we left off last time, you had just told me about Kermit's passing. At that time,
your children were grown, almost everybody was out of the house and in college
except for Kermit. Kermit still here. She was in the sorority house. She was the same
Kappa. And then when her dad died, by then she moved home to be with me. He did. And she
was engaged and to be married in June of that year, he died in February. And so she
said she'd come home and stay with me. And so I got to know my future son-in-law
quite well during that period. But it was a very tough time to be enthusiastic about
a wedding. And you know, I knew Kermit wasn't going to be with us. So anyway, that was
where that stood, I guess. Did you have other friends and that sort of thing at that era
who were really a comfort to you sort of took you through that difficult? No, not really.
Well, I shouldn't say that. There were a couple of couples that really stood by me. But
it's amazing in that era. And I think it's true today when you are no longer a couple,
it's a different story. Different socials. Yes. And I had one lady tell me very bluntly.
She said, well, I won't be inviting you to dinners anymore. It makes an uneven number.
Interesting. Yeah. And so, you know, people see things differently. But I'm Izzy Hall
of CH2M Hall. She was a, she and Jim were wonderful support. And I've all, and now I'm
kind of supporting them because Jim has a disease that we will not get well from. And
so I try to take her out to lunch and do things with her now. So you know, it all comes
full circle. Yes, it does. Yeah, that's an interesting statement to, because I think that
has probably changed in this generation. I don't think there is that same sense that
you only socialize with couples. There's a lot more relationships among women. Yes, that's
right. Good support. And there was at that time. And you've probably built those kind of
relationships gradually as you will. Yes. And, and you know, the thing of it is that I
think that people don't realize when you're in your 50s what it's going to be like when
you're alone, when you're in your 80s. And people are much more aware of that, I think
now, than they used to be. People were more self-centered, I think. And then the other thing
that I think about my life is that Herman and I did everything together. We were big on going
places with other couples. We went with our family. We went, we went fishing. We went, he went
hunting with the boys. And I did my little things with the hospital and that sort of thing.
But basically we did our social things just together. Yes. So you had a really special bond and
that's that's hard to recreate. That's right. Or substitute. So what kind of things did you do in
that time to kind of move you through the through the morning stage and help you plan the wedding.
And that was a full time job. I can imagine. And of course when a person dies there's so much to
take care of. And as I've mentioned before I had very little money that was coming in routinely.
I had to figure out how I was going to support myself and whether I had to go back to work or what
I was going to do. Because we had a lot of assets but we didn't have any cash flow. And so I hired a man
to manage my first lands that were left over from the mail. And as I've said before I trusted him
implicitly but I really didn't feel like I had a handle on it because I didn't know anything about
Timberland and managing it. And so he did a lot of work on
I don't know what they call that. He drew pictures of the forest and then where we should log and
what we should do with different sections of it. And I wish I could put that better. But anyway that went
on for a couple of years. And when I needed some money I'd say you know you got them log.
But then I decided that after I got my wits about me and got kind of settled down I thought well
you know I know a lot about real estate and how that works. So I think I'll do it 1031 just like my
father did. And so I sold off the timber manager surveyed the timberland that I wanted to sell first
and to see how much I could get from that. And so then I found a building that I could buy.
And so we changed those two and that worked out so well that I did it four more times.
Because that gave you at least a regular source of that's right because I had the money coming in
from the rents from the real estate. And then I knew how much I had to spend.
So anyway that worked out very well and it's still to this day I own those properties.
He said the by-mart property was one of those two.
Well the by-mart was a little different because I had inherited that from my mother's estate.
And so that was a little bit different but it also had a 30 year lease on it which was
just peanuts. You know because it was so such an old lease. Yeah why my father did that I do not know
but anyway there wasn't much income from that. I see. Not like it is today. Yeah.
Is that still your property today? Yes. I own that corner there.
Ninth and circle and it's been very now that I have a decent lease.
Well it gives me some income. That's good. So you got involved in your real estate business and
was at the time that you sort of started getting involved in community activities now?
Yes. And I had always been interested in the hospital because
my dad had always he was one of the movers and chakers when the hospital was in bankruptcy
down here on the Harrison Street. And he and a group of other men pulled that hospital out of
the the the got it going again. And then my husband was interested in the hospital and served on
the board of the hospital when they moved from Harrison out to the hill. And so I was always
involved in the auxiliary and my mother and Mrs. Ed Woodcock were the two ladies who started
the held a tea and asked women to come and that's how the auxiliary started the present hospital.
That's interesting. So that we were always involved as a family more or less in the hospital.
And of course I I'm a wind curmud guy. They need me. I am an honorary trustee of the
trustee board. And so I've been very active in that and helped raise money for
the various projects that they've had like the Pashtaga house. I was
co-chair with the heart center with with Mario Pashtaga. And then I also supported him when he
wanted to do his house. They call it the house. So he and I worked together real closely on that.
Yeah. Fundraising for the most part. Yes. And I were you also involved in a cancer center there
at the hospital? Yes. And they're the hallway out in that building is named for a curmud.
Was that his project as well? No. Not really. I think that was pretty much my project.
But it was one of the first fundraising projects that I had.
Because I knew a lot of people in town. And I kind of knew who to ask.
Yeah. That's what's important.
You have a long list of things that you've been involved with here. And I could ask you about
each one of them. But you could also just tell me to direct me a little bit. Which ones you feel
are your major points of pride? Well of course the park is very much. And that was an interesting
how that came about. I yielded or built this house. And when we were through building it,
he came to me and asked me if I would loan him some money to he owned the corner where the park is.
And he asked he had plans drawn up and he was going to build a big high rise,
something rather there of office buildings. And I said no I said I don't think that's what
ought to be on that corner. And I said the chamber is next door. You're going to hide the chamber
of commerce building. And as people come over the bridge, they will not see where the chamber is.
And I said I don't think that ought to be built on that corner. Well he picked up on that.
Within I think it was just two or three weeks. It was very short period of time.
There was a consensus between the university, the city, and the chamber. And they all pitched in
and bought that property from Ike. And then they came to me and asked if I would landscape it.
And so that's how Kermit's name is on that part. I see. So that all worked out just fine. Everybody
was happy. And I still look after it. And I get after him when they don't keep the park up because
I have also donated funds to the N County Foundation for the purpose of keeping that park up.
And they're supposed to use it for the, you know, to put in some perennials and that sort of thing.
And now I'm after the chamber because their trees have grown up so much that you can't see
their building. And I think they ought to take those trees down. And so that when people come
over the bridge they can see where the chamber is. That's true. Yeah. So anyway I'm working on that.
It's good. Never stop that kind of thing. Keep them spiffed up there.
Now let's see. The other thing I think is that I belong to the homeic.
And that was started. My interest in that was a long long long ago.
Azeria Saker was the lady in charge of the homeic part of the state extension service.
And she and I had known each other because of course I'd grown up in Kervalis and they lived not far
from us. Well, when I was teaching school up in McKenzie by she called me one day. Was that in
Wades? Well, taking the job within class up for that. No, no, no. This is different day.
So I was up the McKenzie teaching and that summer before the summer was out. She called me
wanting to know if I wanted to job in Lane County doing work with people who wanted to process
their produce, either canning or freezing or whatever. And I said, oh, I'd love a job for the summer.
So she said, well, fine. And so then about halfway through the summer, why she called me and she said,
we have an opening in an Astoria for a war food assistant. And this is during the war.
Yes, you did tell me about that. Oh, okay. Well, then I won't repeat that.
Okay. And so that's how I got into the extension service because then the war food assistant was
then the class of county liked what we did up there with the women. And so they asked,
they, you see, extension services is funded by federal state and county funds. And so the county
was going to go ahead and do their part to fund the extension service and that guy was still going.
But I started that whole program up there. So that was part of the state home economic system?
Yes. And then you became a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, what they call a home demonstration age.
An administration. Otherwise known as a home demon.
That's kind of a positive and a negative. That word I guess you could see.
Huh. And then eventually you became the chair of the College of Home Economic Development Council.
Yes. That was the step that you took.
Yes. That was when a Kinsey Green was Dean. And I was a chairman of the advisory committee for
probably six or seven years. And then when Tammy Brave became the dean, why she asked me to
continue. However, we don't have a chairman. I don't think as such. We just have advisory committee.
I see. And what are the some of the projects that you did through that group that you're
going to do? Well, we, we raise money too for the, for the college. And we, we talk about where
the college is going, what, what needs to be done, what needs to be processed in the way of
whatever we think that people ought to be thinking about like, you know, they come,
when Tammy Brave took over that dean ship, it was combined with the College of Physical Education.
I think it was. And then they call it Health and Human Science. And so she came to me and wanted
to know about the history of home economic side of that. And then she had the other group.
And we formed them together. So now we do both. I see. And is that the group that started the
Bates Family Study Center? Yes. And I was on that committee to, to help with that.
What is the purpose of that, that study center? It's mostly studies.
And either children development, which is the, the have a, they have a
archery nursery school there. And, and also gerontology.
I don't know.
There's a gerontology department also. And, so, but it's expanded a lot since we started. I think
there's lots of research goes on on there. I don't know. I think the, the bone density
project is probably in the basement of the women's building. I don't think it's over at the
Bates Center. But it's all intertwined. All that research. So the Bates Center is an actual
building. Yes. Yes. And, and, and, well, I was on the committee that helped fund that.
We raised quite a bit of money for that. Among them was the lady who was
the, the original Betty Crocker. And she was a graduate of Oregon State.
I didn't realize that. Yes. And, so, I'm trying to forget her knee. I think.
Anyway, she didn't, she, she came out here from and worked with us to get this, to get it going.
And took a big interest in it. And, of course, left us the big sum of money that the major donor
of that building, because it's named after her. Well, she didn't like much staying downtown at the
hotel. So, she used to come and stay with me. So, I enjoyed being with her because we, we had an
awfully good time when she stayed with me. And then I would take her, you know, around where she
wanted to go. That time I drove a lot better than I drive now. And so, I provided transportation
for her. What fun. So, she, was she older than you? Oh, yes. She's been gone many years now.
Yeah, she, she began to go downhill during the time that she gave the money to the
family study center. And then the last time she came out, she really wasn't herself. She came
with a gentleman who was her, oh, I don't know with you, calling him a kind of a consultant for their
money. And he took kind of, took over caring for her to, but she stayed with me and he stayed
downtown. That's fun. So, I asked Mercedez Bates. That's her thing. Mercedez Bates. That's her
thing. Yeah. So, you're an awful way to forget people like that. I just did it earlier today. So,
so you were also involved in the 4-H foundation at the state level? Yes, because my, I had,
I think we talked about that when, when I was growing up, I had the daughter of the head of the
state. Harry Seymour was head of the state. And I had her, his daughter for my 4-H teacher,
our leader, I guess you'd say. And so, I was always active in 4-H and when my children came along,
my they were active in 4-H. And both of the girls had, they were state winners and they're,
in the dress competition and they, they took, I taught them some, but they had a great leader,
Mrs. Wells was her name. They lived out on the corner of Walnut in 20.
Where's the stop sign at Walnut before you go up the hill?
The hill, there's a stop, light there, stop late at 27th and then 1 at 29th.
Well, I think it's the 1 at 29th because that's the one where you go out 29th and go up and
around the hill and then down. Well, she lived at that corner and why she was a great leader.
She knew a lot about sewing and I thought it was better for the girls to get it from
somebody else than me. So, they went out there and sewed a lot for her.
And then my dad was one of the movers and shakers along with
the, Bert and Bert and the guy that was head of the state 4-H, his name.
We'll have to look that up because I don't remember what I, Bert and sticks in my,
Bert and Bert and Hutton.
Hutton? Maybe that was the name.
I can check on that too.
Put a question mark on that because I don't know for sure.
Anyway, Bert and Hutton came, well, just say that's who it is.
Came to my dad and he wanted to buy this property over in Salem that was for sale and it was
Timberland. And so my dad went over there and the idea was to build a camp for 4-H's.
Well, it was a pretty big project and my dad was very involved in that.
And so then when it came along, I was a treasure, I think.
I don't know. I was some officer in the 4-H program that was established to run that camp.
At the state level?
Yes. And eventually we had to sell off half of the Timberland, which just killed me
because it was should have been self-sustaining. But you know, people don't realize that Timber
is a renewable resource and you just harvested every 40 years instead of every year like a lot of
crops. And so we could have, if we've been able to save that land, we could have had it rotating
so that we could have always had some income but didn't work out. But they did save half of it.
And now we've got a really wonderful fundraiser, Randy, his name, but I know what his last name is.
But he's great and he is running the camp and they're just, and they're getting
what do you call it? They're
I want to say they're applying for fundraising for grants.
For grants?
Yes, yes. And so now they're just doing really well and they're able to keep it up and it looks
great. And so I was involved in that as being on the 4-H board. And so I became very interested
in that because I wanted to see it go. And my dad provided money for the swimming pool of that
camp and then Kermit and I gave some money for the upkeep of it.
It seems like in general you had a few that swimming related gifts that you gave.
Yes. Because there are special reason that you were interested in.
Well, we were always thought that swimming was very important for Oregonians because we have so
much water and when we would see people drown because they couldn't swim, we thought
that was just terrible. And so we've always supported water-related activities.
And I still do that because I support through the Benton County Foundation. I support
all for instance lifts for people to get in and out of pools so they can swim.
And then I think we already talked about the girls going to camp.
To a spring win. Yes. And they didn't want to go back because it wasn't any swimming pool.
So Kermit and I talked it over and we'd made some money in the stock market. And so we decided we'd give
stock to them and so they built their swimming pool. But we wouldn't let anybody know that we'd
done that because we didn't want the kids to go to camp and everybody saying,
they gave to the swimming pool. So it's never been named or anything.
I think that's interesting. We didn't want the kids to know.
Yeah. So did your family always have a swimming pool?
Yes. We always had.
And your kids were growing up.
At least when Kermit and I, we always had a swimming pool. Of course my dad didn't because he
he supported the 4-H one but he didn't support family.
But we did have a pond out in the woods that we could use in the summertime.
Kermit was I think, did I tell you about him building that swimming pool?
No.
Well, when we built our house over on Jackson Street we didn't have a swimming pool.
And so he came home one day and he said, what would you think if we put build a swimming pool
across on the property across the way that we owned? And he said, I could bring in 12 by 12
timbers and put them together in the corners. And then we could put your paper down for the paint job
and then put plastic around it. And it would be 4 feet deep.
And I said, well, I think that would be great because the kids were little and they could
they could have a lot of fun and it was just like a big puddle pool.
So we did that and that I think that lasted for probably, oh probably five or six years every year
we would tear it down and re-put your paper in plastic and it would last the summer.
And then we decided we'd build a swimming pool. So we did that and
but it wasn't covered. And so that wasn't very satisfactory in Oregon.
So when he closed the mail, he came to me and he said, I've got to take the metal off the roof
of some of the machinery that are in the mail. And he said, if we cleaned it up and cut off the
end where the logs have hit it, he said, I could bring that metal in and we could have a building
over the pool. And I said, no thank you. I don't want a metal building in my yard.
And he said, well now just wait a minute. How tell you about how we're going to do this?
It's better than you think. So anyway, the back part of it was all metal and then we put
boards that was a very nice awning over the front of it. That was all wood and then we had
sliding glass doors and from the street you couldn't tell what it was.
It's still there. So it covered over the whole pool?
Yeah, it's interesting. And we built a sink and a bathroom out there and a boys and girls
dressing rooms. Wow. And it was really a nice little, okay. And of course we entertained all
of the kids and on the campfire girls, the boy scouts, the 4-H kids, whoever came around.
This was wonderful because the kids were at our house and we knew what they were doing.
Absolutely. And so it was just a wonderful pool for the kids all the time they were growing up.
That's great. And so that's still in use over there?
Oh yeah, so. That's good. Well that sort of leads me to my, I wanted to ask a little bit about
Kermit's community involvement because I know it sounds like he was also involved in the scouts
to a certain event. Yes, yes. With the scouts in Eugene, I don't know what level of scouting
that was but whatever it was he used to go down the Eugene to meetings with boy scouts and it was
very active and he did a lot of fundraising for the boy scouts and he always said that he didn't
like to ask people for money but because of his relationship with the male, there were lots of
times when he had partial lots of something that he couldn't really sell but they were very usable
so he would donate those. He liked in kind giving and he got canoes for the boy scouts and he
would ask various people who manufactured things if he thought the scouts could use it but then he
and that worked very well. In fact, I still do that a lot with my fund raising. We try to get
in kind gifts because people don't mind giving things that they've manufactured that
and those canoes were perfectly good but maybe they had a chip out of the paint or something they
couldn't sell but they were perfectly usable. Interesting. That's a great service to provide.
Yes. So, in giving was his thing. Interesting. He was also involved with the rotary and
and other groups around town. Yes, he was a Rotarian and after he died, I made him a fellow in the
Rotary Club and he was really fond of the Rotary Group. Were there some things that he was particularly
involved with that things in close to him? I don't remember that he was in particularly involved
with Rotary but he may have been more than I realized I don't know. But he was involved in the
church. He was a justee of the church. He did that and he wasn't a joiner really. He didn't like to
join very much really. So, he did his work on the outskirts of the church? Yes. That works that well.
Another thing I have on the list of your credits is the EE Wilson Foundation. What's been your
involvement there? Well, I was on that for a number of years and Fred Zawallon was head of that
and managed it from the very beginning when EE Wilson died and I knew EE Wilson and so I guess
they thought that I would be interested in managing what he had given to the college and
what really wasn't to the college it was just I think it was kind of just given but he had to have a
board managing it and Pete Smith lived next door to us over on Jackson and he was on the board
and so then he got me involved and I was on that for a number of years.
Is that managing the lands or the money that was in the bank that was accumulating interest
and so forth and the duty of the board was to have kids apply for money from that and then we had
to read their applications and decide who was going to get what. So scholarships for OSU?
Yes. Well it could be, as I remember it it could be any I've kind of forgotten I think it's any
Oregon school and I can't remember. That scholarship is still available I see it is.
Yes it is. It's a big surprise. It seems to me like it has to be Benton County youth.
Hmm, it could be. I think it is. Boy that was a long time ago when I served on that.
I see you haven't done that for a while. No. So most recently the things that you're still
involved in are you still involved in the 4-H or the economic? No I'm still I serve on
the advisory committee for the HOMEC, HOMEC, Health and Human Science and the library
and the hospital is an honorary trustee and the museum of Benton County Museum.
That's a lot of responsibilities. Well I've quit the just recently I've quit the museum
and I've quit the library so I'm down to the hospital and the Health and Human Science.
And you've quit them just to give yourself a little more free time? Yes. Yes. It's just too much.
It is but it's an incredible gift to the community. Do you think that as you were talking about
how you had a good year in the stocks or whatever and then you'd give to this cause or another?
Do you think that's still going on at that same level in in this day and age? That's the same
sense of philanthropy that people of your era had? No I don't think so. I think everything now is
based on what I can do to get rid of the money for tax purposes. Hmm. I really think that people give
to get their tax off. And of course I've always believed that I would like to give money
to something where I know it's going, then to taxes. So I try to give as much as I can
and not have to pay tax on it. Yeah. But it seems like your choice of beneficiaries has a lot
to do with your personal interests. Oh yes, absolutely. It's your way. Yes. You're personally involved
not only in terms of giving money but also in giving an expertise and advice. Yeah. Because
I want to know what they're doing with the money that come out. I think that makes you different
than some other donors too in some ways. Oh probably. A lot of people give money
and then they look to done. You know they don't pay attention. But I really like to know what they're
doing with it. Absolutely. The one big organization that you've given to is OSU. We haven't talked
about that at all. But I'd love to hear more about your involvement there and all the things that
you've contributed. I know a lot of it has been real estate fundraising for various real estate
ventures. Oh is that true? Well I think that when you know a lot of all of this stuff that goes
on is who you know. And I'm really proud of the fact that there were three ships available
or fishing vessels I should say available in Newport. And I had been cut, become very friendly
with Bruce made in his wife Mary-Due and his mother because they wanted me to go on a trip
and his mother needed a roommate. So I said well I would go and room with her. Well we just got
along fine and we just became really good friends over Newport. So anyway the more I heard about
what Bruce made was doing I was very impressed with what he does and his science that he's
promoted with whales. So anyway there were some when the fishing industry over there we kind of
went kaput by the were three men who wanted to donate their boats to as you for research.
Well the trustees who were the people who say yes or no there's a little you know board
that does that. They didn't know what did they do about Bruce made and never heard of him didn't
know anything about him. Well I had followed him because he's on BBC and he's on
history channels and all of those things and he was doing great things about tagging whales so that
they knew where they were going and what they were doing. And so John Irving was one of the men who
was trying to get the board the boys you board to accept these these ships because he thought it was a
great thing for them to be able to re retrofit them and get them fixed for research. Well so far
they've only done one but they're available but anyway backing up he called me one day and he
said would I be willing to speak to the trustees about Bruce made and I said oh I'd love to because
I really think he does a good job. So anyway I told him I said how many of you know Bruce the name
Bruce made. They looked at each other. So I proceeded to tell him who he was and what he'd done and
what wonderful research he was doing. So then they were all skittery ship out insurance on these
boats but they finally worked it out with I don't know who but anyway they accepted the three boats
and I'm really proud of the fact that I kind of encouraged him to do so. So Lutley yeah.
But you know sometimes it's just who you know. That's right and having that personal touch.
I'm willing to be there and say yeah I know of this man and I can speak for him. That's right.
And I can tell him a little bit about what he does. His mother I don't know whether you want to put
anything about this in but I think she's such a tear woman. She's just a little short thing.
She's probably not five feet tall. She studied under Frank Lloyd Wright and his registered architect.
She studied a library of science and as a degree in whatever library is and she's this one smart lady.
She's just a there and has a wonderful sense of humor. Just enjoyed her knowing.
Oh, that's great. Unfortunately now she's in a rest home in Newport but doesn't have her mind
very clear right now but she's getting older with some of the rest of us.
So you've done some work as a lot of work through the foundation as well through the OSU foundation?
Well I'm on the OSU foundation. I wouldn't say I do much work but I go and I see. So that's more of being a member
of the board and not necessarily anything. Things that you're most proud of.
No, in fact I'm not very proud of what they're doing right now. We won't put that in.
We won't. Okay. All right. You say so. Are there things that OSU that you look at and think I don't
I'm so pleased beyond the both that you that you got for Bruce's project but are there other things there
that you look at and think I'm so glad to have been a contributor to this. Well the library of course
I think our library is just one of the nicest ones in the Northwest. It's amazing.
And I'm very supportive of Carol Butcher. I think she does some very innovative things.
The most recent one that she's done is having that babysitting area that she has and the students
can come and bring if they're studying in the library they have to stay in the library but if
they're studying they can bring their children and let them off at this little care center.
And they they're given a thing like you get in restaurants you know when you're
beeper. So kind of a beeper? Yes a beeper and so if they need them they can be the mother
and our father was a case maybe these days and and I think that's quite innovative. I didn't know
about that. Yes it's quite a nice project. They have a little they they've done some interesting
things with the plumbing because of course they needed to toilet and it's a little really nice
little porta potting and so they didn't put in actual plumbing but I think it's very well designed
and they have students in there that are learning childcare. I think it's just a great project.
Oh I'll have to check that out. Terrific. Well and you're such a beaver fan. Oh yes I'm a beaver.
That should definitely be in there too I think. Well you know since I've lived in Kervellis all my
life there's no and you know I had three out of my four children go through Oregon State so
where and my husband was a graduate of Oregon State and and I've worked for the college through
the extension service and you know we've just been involved in the university all our lives. Sure
yeah and of course my father worked at the university and you know you're just kind of all
that's where your life has been. That's right yeah but I love I love the fact that you still go to
the football games. Oh yes oh yes oh that football game Saturday night was something.
It's like that they're doing so well this year. He was just so proud. But although he officiating was
aww. Was it cool? He was just terrible. Huh. And even Mike Riley who calls the games for the radio
he said it was the worst officiating he'd ever seen in my life. That's a statement. Yes.
And the the paper I think Riley asked him to downplay it probably but he's a very low key guy
but boy was he upset to see officiating he called one of the plays you know and asked him to read
read through it. Really? And they and they they did change it. So yeah it was a it was a feisty game.
Good. You're good. And you still go to those with your family? Yes. In fact I did go with my daughter
and son-in-law this time. I always sometimes I use tickets for guests. I like to entertain that way.
You know because I have the tickets I might as well use them for something. That's right.
Well that's your your support of the sports angle of the OSU in general it seems like that's
a particular emphasis for you. Yes and I like I really like basketball better. I go to all the
basketball games. You're not doing very well on basketball this year but of course when Ralph Miller
was there why it was just wonderful. Well that's good. So are there any other projects that you think
you'd like to talk about in here things that you're particularly proud of?
Well I guess I'm particularly proud of my kids. Well that's it I would love to get back to that
because we sort of talked about their younger life when we were here a couple weeks ago but I'd
like to hear about about them today and what you what you're most proud of of each of them.
Well Ken's the oldest and he lives in Southern California and he has two sons and the grandchildren
are doing most most welcome. Derek is the his oldest son and he's married to Mindy and they
have three children now and they're cheesy. What do they call that school? Modestory school teacher
and has a school in their home and Derek is very handy and he's made a dollhouse and he's made
slides and he's made they have half their yard for the school and half the yard for their
own private and the kids know when they come that they don't go on that side of the yard
but they just do a whale of a job they're growing up to be such fine young people.
That's wonderful and I'm very proud of them and my kin lives in I don't know what Ken does and I
he's on the California Water Board he does something about that he's also done something with
hazardous waste he's been on committees about that. Is he an engineer? No he really isn't he's
he was a business major he started out as being a forest major but he every time he went to class
he I've failed trip he had poison oak and so he had to give that up and so he was a business major
and then he got his NBA and
something but um
but he's he's dabbled in a lot of things and he lives in on 10 acres in an avocado grove and raises
those great big avocados. Oh yes those are great.
Oh that's so good and and um and his wife is a psychologist and the children all call her the
shrink. That's great and their second son and the second one it was in the military. What's his name?
Danny. Danny, huh? And he was in the military for about 10 years I think and married a really nice
girl and they have two children and he's out of the military now and taking auto mechanics and
well I guess you'd say mechanics because I think it's a combination of auto and airplane
the mechanics he likes to work with his hands so he does that then crags the next boy
and he um is uh lives in bend and um he does um well I don't know what Craig does
he runs some sort of a business called bad checks and it's he takes checks that are bouncing
and does something with him and I've never been able to figure out what he does but anyway he does
that and then he um he's a hunter and a fisherman and um seems to earn enough money to play
quite a bit and he also has some friends who are quite wealthy and he goes with them a lot because
Craig's a fun guy um and um he has told him as well? Yes he has too and what is going to school here
in at LBCC and is going to be she's studying to be a
um now I don't know what she's studying to be anyway she's going to school
uh huh what's her name? Tracy Tracy and then Mackenzie goes to
scad which is Savannah College of Art and Design in Savannah Georgia and she's studying jewelry
and she apparently is very good because uh she just designed some piece that the teacher is
taking to Hong Kong to show since some group that are over there and I guess it's quite a
thing in her body. She um has been thinking that she would like to buy a Savannah house you know
an antique house of some sort and have a store below what you restore below and have a live above
so she's got her little life all figured out. Then there's Kathy who lives in Portland KATH Y
and um she's married to um meet Clifford and um and which is kind of interesting because you know
we have a man over here who was Clifford Mead and the uh in the uh uh
Alinas Paul and Insta-Jay to the University. So anyway um you gotta be careful with which way you get that
um uh and he um was a man who uh man um he called it uh uh what did he call that business
anyway it was storing hospital records and he built that up to a very big business
and then all of a sudden Iron Mountain came in and uh they were an international company and
they bought him out so he does some other things now. Did they have children? Yes they have three
and it's um the oldest one is Brent and he goes to school at oh I can't tell you it's it's a
one of the California schools it's San Diego. It's the Catholic school that's in San Diego up on the
hill. I can bet it. Very prestigious school but I never know whether it's the university uh no
I don't think it's got university in it because it's a private it's a Catholic school they are
Catholic but he wanted to go to someplace where he could wear flip-flops and shorts. He found it.
So he's and he's I'm going to graduate this year and he thinks he's going to go to law school.
Great and then Colin is the high school senior I don't know what I'm going to do about
graduation this year. We've got all these kids graduating. Mackenzie will graduate from SCAD.
Brent's going to graduate from California. Colin's going to graduate from Lincoln High School
and you know how do I want to be able to go? You'll have to map it out with a calendar.
Um that's Colin and he goes to Lincoln High School. What's his interest you know?
Um well the poor kid he's had health problems and he wants to be an athlete but he
just had his tonsils out and it was a real brutal operation. He was in the hospital for two or
three days with tonsils. Yeah he don't hear about that much anymore. They say that when you're older
and you have your tonsils out it's real rough and it was he just had a few days there of
being miserable. So I don't know what Colin will be interested in. He's looking at schools now
and then there's little Brent who is interested in nothing but LaCrosse. Now you said Brent was
the oldest? Yes. Then Colin and then Brent. No Brent? I see I got two Brent somehow. Oh who is the old?
Oh I'm sorry. Okay. Grant is what I meant. Grant is the oldest. Okay Colin and then
Brent. Alright. And Grant's LaCrosse. Well that's his, the sleep eats everything LaCrosse and I
guess he's a pretty good little player because he was chosen as one of two in the Portland district
to represent the teams that play. He's played in Philadelphia and this is a middle school.
Huh? Oh he's still in middle school. That's amazing. And he played in Philadelphia and he played
in Seattle and he played in Southern California and you understand that. I think that's too much
for middle school kids. Oh yeah but that's what they do these days. Oh yes it sure is and I guess
he's pretty darn good. So that's his passion. And then there's Kim. She's the baby and she's
married to Walt and she and Walt are now doing the courtyard. You know what I mean about the courtyard.
Yeah. And that's Revivalence. Revivalence. Like they call it and they've been working really hard
to get the students to get it fixed up so that students can live there. It was in terrible shape.
And they've got 14 students living there. And they're the nicest young people.
They have to be kind of religiously oriented. Not any particular denomination.
Just and they're all enthusiastic about where they live and they're spreading the word and
Kim said by next year they'll have a waiting list. I'm sure. Yeah. So are they living here in
town while they work here? Yes they live out at the end of 29th street. Oh great. Clear up in the
hills. Because otherwise did she live in Portland before? Yes. Uh huh. Has she moved completely
down here? Uh and yes. Walt's been an interesting husband. He's he ran and he was an FFA boy.
And he when he finished college he had six screenhouses and ran a nursery.
Took up to a cardiculture in college. But he's gone through all the work for a rubber company
and he worked for, he's always landed on his feet with a very good job. But now they're deciding
that they'll do this. So who knows what they'll do. And she was a teacher? Yes. Uh huh.
Now she was trained as a teacher. She's not doing that anymore? No. She's working with Walt.
Revolves. Okay. She was substituting when they lived in Portland. Uh huh. Great. And they have twin
daughters. Uh huh. Jennifer and Kristen. Uh huh. And Kristen is, um, she graduated from
Seattle Pacific. And in business and has a job in Portland with a computer company that she
hates her job but gets good money. And Jennifer has graduated in home economics. We're
helping human science. Uh huh. And uh has a job in Portland that she just loves but doesn't make much
money. So often it's a trade off. But it's fun that she's continuing on in the home economics field.
Well no she manages an office for some brokers. Oh she does. She has her degree but she doesn't use it.
Oh. Oh. Well still she has the same interest that you did in home economics. It's nice that you
share that. Well yes. Uh huh. She she did and she worked a lot in kid spirit when she was here.
And school she worked at kid spirit almost all the time she was here. So um it's wonderful that
you can even name all these grandchildren and talk about each of them individually. Did you
spend a lot of time with them when they were growing up? Well more so with Kim's children than
the rest of them because they were in Portland. And um well I spent time with with Kathy's children when
they were younger but I don't drive to Portland anymore so I don't see them nearly as often as I
use to. Uh huh. But I know they stay in touch just from the fact that last time I was here one of
somebody called maybe one of your California grandchildren. Oh. Oh yeah they all call. We were
wonder we think cell phones are just great. That's good. Yeah. What were some of the things that
you did with them when you could get to spend time with them? Well we we shopped a lot and uh
they're they're they love to shop with grandma because you know who's buy some stuff. Oh my
guess at the same. But we we did a lot of things together. We had a lot of picnics together.
Did you ever share your cooking and sewing in those kind of skills with them? Well not much maybe
maybe naked sugar cookies. They all like my sugar cookies. And this this holiday I'm taking the
rolls and the sugar cookies for my part of the Thanksgiving dinner. Oh that's good. And last night
Craig said I said something about boy who had taken me a long time to make rolls. I said I just
got as fast as I used to be. And he said well don't worry about the rolls just bring the sugar
cookies. Got priorities that's a good thing. So that's kind of the thing that I'm noted for.
Did you have that experience of just finding out how much fun it was to be a grandparent
as with you know enjoying your time with them and not having quite as much of the work as you do
when you're a parent. Well I loved to when Kim had her twins because she lived in Lebanon at that time.
And Walt was still doing the nursery. And so when she and Walt were married she had another year
to go in school. She was married when she was a junior and Walt was a senior. But her daddy had
said I don't mind you getting married but he said you're going to finish school.
Well of course what happened was that she got pregnant. And then they found out they were having
twins. And of course in the meantime he died. And so anyway I said you know you promised your daddy
that if you got married and she said I know. So anyway I said my advice to you is to kept busy
and she only had her doom teaching to do. And I said you need to do that before your kids get
mobile. I said it's a lot easier to take care of them when they're in the in the
not wandering around. And Walt was home during the day because he was running the nursery.
So there was an emergency he was there so that worked out well. So anyway Kim was able to get a
student teaching situation in Lebanon. So she wasn't far away and so she finished up and got
her degree while she was doing that. And then but I was over there a lot taking care of the youngsters
and they'd have full time help but it was you know I like to go over there and help feed the kids.
I can imagine. She was a great mother. She twins didn't bother Kim at all. I can still see her
sitting on the dab important one. Baby would be laying over there and she'd be feeding this one
and that one would be yelling and she'd pat him on the back and say now it's your turn next.
Good for her. She was a wonderful mother. Great. So the last time when I was here and you got
that phone call you were going to be sending down one of your boys jackets to one of your great
grand. Yes. Yes and I did that and he's absolutely ecstatic. That is so sweet. Yeah this would
be born to actually this one was a red, plantable boy scout jacket. I don't know whether you know but
that's quite a deal when they get that. And then they put all their patches on it. And so this one
was all covered in patches and so I said to Ken my son I said what do you think I ought to do
with these patches and he said well I take them off because he needs to earn his own patches.
So anyway I've got them all in a little Ziploc bag and I'm taking them over to Craig who earned
the patches and then sent the coat to the cleaners and it's been sent down to yeah to what's his name?
One of those guys down there. Get the name of the great grandchildren I guess.
Derek Rodinney's kids huh? Yeah well it's Derek's kids. Well anyway whoever's getting it
and he said so Ken called me and he said boy is he one happy boy? He said he's just crazy about
and you know what looked brand new when it got back from the cleaners it was just great. That's
fun. They kind of fluffed up all of the sewing that would have been on it worked out just really well.
That's good. Good. Well are there other things that you have that you saved from when you were
a little girl that you have been able to pass on to your grandchildren that they've enjoyed?
Well I don't really think of anything off-hand.
Oh no I don't. The only thing that I have saved really of Kathie's is that she made a dress with
beautiful satin stitch. I could show that to you. I think it's a real special little dress and
it's been hanging back there for 20 hairs just because I enjoy looking at it.
Uh huh. Do you want to see it? I'd love to. Well let's wait till we're done. We'll go out. We'll
go down there at the end unless you need to get up and stretch a little bit. No no no. I'm
sitting for a while. We're doing here for time. Let's see. Two thirds. We plan to stop at three again.
It's two. It's 20 minutes to three now. How to be fine. Okay. All right. Let's see.
And then we're just about three four. We are. I think this will be our last formal get together.
Oh huh. I want to keep open the possibility of giving you a call while I'm putting this together.
Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Absolutely.
My understanding. So I had some more sort of general questions that are more or less
reflections on life and you could tell me if you're comfortable answering these kinds of things.
But I like to have a little bit of people's philosophy in these books too.
Because I feel like what you're leaving with this book is a statement of your legacy.
One other's there's so much about your death legacy out there. And I think well
Jean has a legacy of her own that she's leaving. She's leaving here.
Do you have a sense of what you want your legacy to be? What do you think your children and your
community should remember about you? Oh gosh. Those are hard things to answer.
I should have given you these questions in advance. Yeah. Because I just hope that people
remember that I've tried to live by the golden rule. I guess it's my philosophy.
I'd like to have people treat me like I want to be treated and I want to treat them.
And I've always kind of lived by that hopefully by that philosophy that
I don't know really what else to say about that. I want to feel like I'm
all I'm on this earth that I'm contributing something to society.
And I guess that that's why I like to get out and do things and I don't want to just sit.
Right. Do you stay active? And we haven't talked about knitting either, have we?
I'd like to hear more. That's one of my hobbies.
You've shown me and you actually told me that you got started on that back when you were
in high school when you were waiting for your dad to pick you up. This piece is coming along nicely
though. Are you getting close to the end of it? Yes, I'm getting quite close to the end of it.
Just love the colors that you chose for that. This is for Colin.
And I've made a knitting. I'm not the end there. Oh, do I?
I'm losing something. Not quite.
I've hit an African for each one of the children. Most of them, at least the ones that have asked for it.
Uh-huh. And so he's a big boy and so he wanted something heavy and his mother wanted something
that he wouldn't put his toes through. Good point. Uh-huh. And so that's for that.
But this one is, and you know, we might take a picture of that one time.
Because I'm most proud of this African.
I think this is the one that I didn't know I was waiting for him when he was a football player.
I've been most of this under a street light.
Waiting in your car while he was at practice? Yes. It's gorgeous.
And I've got a variety of stitches in this one. So I'm really pleased with this one.
Now how did you end up with that if you knitted it for him?
Oh, I didn't knit it for him. I'll just knit it for you.
Wow, he was. He was playing. I did it for myself.
It's just gorgeous. Well, I'm at least a sampler, isn't it, with all the,
yes, it is. It's kind of stitching in it.
But I've knit, I don't know how many of these. I knit one for Uncle Norm. That was my,
my husband's brother. And he, I had a real hard time. They were, when he was getting older,
they just kind of chopped him in pieces. He lost a leg and, you know, an arm and
diabetes? No, I don't know what he had. So long time ago, and I forgot what he had, but anyway,
he needed to blank it to keep warm. He didn't have very good circulation. So I knit him one,
and I get, I don't know how many askings I've made. I might take a picture of that one too before
I leave here. I'd love to have a picture of that to put in the book as well.
Well, I think I'm real proud of this one. Yeah, it's really gorgeous. It's probably the fanciest one
that I've got. And I do needle point. That's a needle point one that I did. Which one? That one.
The pillow? Beautiful. I love the colors. I have a couple at the beach that I've done in shells,
and that sort of thing. I don't have good eyes for that project. Yeah. Tiny little stitches.
I did all of it except the border, and I got to the point where I just couldn't do those fine
stitches. It was, it was pink on the background too, and I couldn't see where, where I'd been,
and where I was going. Yeah. So who finished it up for you? But Kathy, she does. She does beautiful,
needle point. She's, she has inherited more of my clothing and textiles.
Ability, yeah. And anybody else. Kim doesn't like to do that much.
So you've been a single woman for quite a long time. And I'm sure that has its challenges,
but are there parts of that that have been good for you that have helped you to grow?
Well, I think Kermit and I never got to travel very much. We did have that one lovely trip to Japan.
That I think we talked about and how we happened to go to Japan and so forth. But when
this Uncle Norm died, my sister-in-law and I traveled quite a bit, we probably went on five or
six lovely trips, and we traveled in Europe a lot because my husband never wanted to go to Europe.
There was something about the World War II that he just didn't want to go to Europe. But
but we did go a lot to other parts of the world. But anyway, Marie and I traveled quite a bit
together. And I always enjoyed that. And then when my brother died, I bet he, my sister,
and I traveled quite a bit together. So I really enjoyed all of that very much.
So it kind of freed you up to have that kind of experience with other people?
Right, right. And I had enough income then to support some travel. So it worked out well.
Yeah. When you're traveling, you're sort of seeing the world and seeing however other people live,
are there other parts of that whole traveling thing that really appeal to you?
Well, of course Hawaii is my favorite place. Yeah, because it's clean. They speak English.
Money is the same. It's easy, huh? Yeah, it's easy. And of course the weather is always good.
And I don't remember who did we talk about Betty and I owning a condominium over there?
No, although I saw that somewhere else and I meant to ask you about that. So you have a condominium
together? We did. Well, you don't have it anymore? No, well, of course she's gone. She's been gone for
several years. But we were, she had Alzheimer's. And when we decided that we wanted to do this
condominium together, we said that we were just going to let the family use it.
Well, all of a sudden I began to hear people were thanking me for going to here, stay in my condominium.
Well, I thought that she was being a little bit presumptuous, but it turned out that she really
had not remembered that we had this understanding. And so anyway, I said that I didn't give her any
reason why, but I just said that I thought that maybe I wasn't going to be interested in having
the condominium anymore. And she said, well, she'd buy me out. So it was all very name-in-born
everything. And then I realized a few years later that she just really wasn't herself. So it was okay.
And my nephews just couldn't be nicer to me. They're just wonderful boys. That's great.
So when you were in Hawaii, did you do that? You said,
Kermit was a scuba diver early on. Were you a scuba diver as well?
Yes. He taught me how to scuba dive. And we always went snorkeling.
I wasn't comfortable going by myself too much. And so he would always take my hand and
go out together and look and then he'd say, but Betty and I did a lot of that too because she liked
to snorkel. So when we had our condominium, we would go snorkeling almost every day.
Oh, that sounds wonderful. How long did you have it together?
About three years. That's great. Good. And I think most of the kids had it once or twice.
They all went over once or twice. They were at the age where they didn't have a lot of extra
money for the fare over and then along the staying. And so they could manage it every once in a while,
but not too often. Yeah. That sounds like a real treat. And you had taken them over quite a bit
when they were younger. Yes. We'd always gone over on spring break. That's fun.
You know one thing we didn't talk about. I know that Kermit was involved in the church and you've
always been involved with the church as well. Do you consider yourself a spiritual person?
Well, I think I am more... I think I'm not a... I don't talk about religion too much.
My daughter and son-in-law Kim and Walter are very religious in me. They talk about it all the time
and they pray before heels and that sort of thing. I'm more of a one who keeps their religion
kind of to themselves. And my husband... I think I've got a lot of his feelings in me because he
always said that if he dealt with some businessman who broadcast his religion and had visible
things on his desk that portrayed his religion, it just raised a red flag with him because he
said, I know too many men who go to church every Sunday and just pull back by you during the week.
And I think I've inherited a lot of that feeling. I try to live by the golden rule as I say.
All right, well we have just about five more minutes and I think I can
limit us to maybe three questions. Okay, in that time the other sort of big picture issue I wanted
to ask you about whether there were any sort of social or political issues that have been
important to you as you've come through your life. Are there any things that have been...
Well, I'm a firm believer that you should... What is it about the babies? I think it should
between your husband and your doctor and yourself. And I'm really
myth that people can't see that, that it's none of the government's business.
It's your pro choice. Yeah, I'm sure am.
And have you ever been active in any of those kind of causes or have just a personally held
belief? I'm not in a cause person. That's good. You've been active in
causes sort of in the back. By your influence, yeah. And I guess the other thing is that in church too,
that I feel that if you want to be a... What are you when you're lesbian, I guess?
You know, the congregational church is a big on people being lesbians. And I had to give up
the congregational church even though with my background is in the congregational church. But
it's also in the Presbyterian church. But I'm a Presbyterian now because I could... They hired a lady.
I don't know the remember this, but probably 10, maybe 15 years ago,
a lady came and was part of the Presbyterian church. And I think she was the
Sunday school teacher that they hired the young people. And she thought that lesbians were just
the best thing that ever happened to anybody. And she would have... When she first came,
there was a picture of her in the paper almost every week about what she believed in. And I thought,
I am just sick of that. And so the minister came to see me and I said, do you advertise what goes
on in your bedroom? Well, no. And I said, well, I don't know why lesbians have to advertise that
that persuasion. And so I said, I'm just not going to support the church until you change your
rules. And so that's... You've moved on from there now. Yeah. Yeah. And it was more a matter of
the... How public she was being about it. Yes, yes. I don't care. The whole Mac teachers over here
have always lived together. But they haven't advertised what... And a lot of them were just doing it
because they needed friendship. And there's nothing wrong with that. But to advertise,
you know, how you feel about your personal, it just calls me. And I don't mind if you print that.
All right. That's an important stance. I think that's good.
If you had to pinpoint what you're grateful for in this life, you've talked so much about your
family and things like that. Are there particular things that you think about how grateful you are to
have had in your life? Yes, I think I'm grateful for the fact that I've had a good education.
And that I have been able to use it in many different ways. And that I've been able to contribute
to society. Yes. And that I've been able to earn enough money to live comfortably.
And to share what you have. Yes. Are there... Is there anything that feels sort of unfinished
about your life at this point? Are there things that you still have left to do or that you feel like
you would like to do better? Well... No, I don't really think there's any unfinished business.
Well, I don't know that I had any great broad plans to do anything. It kind of all just sort of evolved.
That's life. I don't think I had any grand notions of what I could accomplish or anything.
It was just that when the opportunity came and I could see that I could help a little bit,
but I took advantage of that. But it wasn't anything premeditated.
Do you have any advice on thinking about your grandchildren and great grandchildren reading this
and wondering if there is anything that you would suggest to them as in terms of kind of an overall
way to live your life? Well, I think the main thing is that you need to be fair and you need to be honest
and you need to take advantage of opportunities that are presented themselves.
And I just think that it's important that you be happy.